susannah is with us in washington hi
Susanna how are you hi David thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up so I discovered you
yesterday and I'm very glad I did
I listen to you all day and I was home
and made a plan I'm 22 I have two kids a
Gina 14 and I you know I make 160 a year
Wow
but I have a $140,000 in student loans
and a car so I know that if I don't no
mind to it I can do it I'm actually it's
an app yesterday and I know that I can
do it so we think that I have an 18 year
old that's going to start to college
this year and I don't have enough saved
up for her so I wanted to know if the
dead of thing off everything and tighten
everything up you know for two year or
three year goal I expended it in five
years but I wanted to know what you
thought about that it's okay I'm not
sure it's your total picture you make a
lot of money and you've done really good
on the income side congratulations what
do you do for a living
ah very good okay okay so the 8 I'm
gonna send you a book called debt-free
degree ok bye Anthony ownio it's a
number one bestseller he's one of our
Ramsay personalities and the book is all
about how your kid can to go to college
without taking on any debt one of the
things is for mom to help and we want
you to help but kiddo has a lot of work
to do
kiddo is going to choose a school that
is very affordable kiddo is going to
apply for a thousand scholarships and
get turned down for most of them but if
they get 20 or 30 of them at $1,000
apiece that'd be a big deal wouldn't it
their new job starting today is applying
for scholarships their new job is
they're going to a school not that they
like how pretty the campus is
but that is affordable because mama is
broke and so is kiddo
so broke people don't go to expensive
schools agreed right yes we already have
that plan to be ready to go to Community
College you good think I was going to be
working a little bit kiddo is going to
be working and paying her stuff and
getting scholarships and you're going to
Community College that's all right
that's a wonderful plan right there for
the first two years in the midst of that
you should not have to contribute much
well if they're if they're working and
they're getting scholarships and they
chose an affordable school and you know
they can do a lot to get themselves
through school so I'll send you the book
that maps that out you guys lay it out
and figure it out together and then yeah
you lay your budget out and say okay I
can put X number of dollars a month
towards your college and the rest of it
we're going to attack this debt with and
the rest of it we're going to live on
nothing beans and rice rice and beans
I have some money in my 401 K which I've
invested into eighteen years ago and I
was wondering I know that you say not to
touch it correct and they stopped
investing in 401 K while you're paying
their debt well you got a lot in one me
excuse me
yes I got a lot I want to put my mind to
something I I went well which we could
and I I did it and I just you know I
want what's best for them and for our
future so I just want to be smart about
it before it's too late you know stop
one day and attack your debt absolutely
you've got a huge amount of debt you've
got to clean it up you are not going to
prosper with this around your neck it's
been around your neck for a long time
hasn't it yeah it hasn't I graduated
three years ago okay but I mean how long
does it take to get tired of a hundred
and forty thousand dollars in debt I'm
already 20 seconds only seconds later
I'm tired of that so yeah you need to
you need to live on nothing and clean
this mess up very very quickly and then
you have the rest of your life to build
wealth and pay college tuitions and
build wealth and in
or your life but right now all your
stinking money is going to student loans
the great news is you got a big shovel
the bad news is you're in pretty good
size hole and you're gonna have to get
with it your kiddo hold on Kelly I'll
pick up we'll get you debt-free degrees
sent out to you so your kiddo can go to
school without going into debt and
without draining mom's pocketbook in the
process